burbujeos de hasta un kilómetro de
diámetro sobresalen del mar Báltico son
la consecuencia visible de las tres
fugas en los gasoductos nordstream 1 y
nordstream 2 que van de Rusia Alemania
un nuevo episodio de tensiones entre
Rusia y Europa y que encendió las
alarmas de marca y Suecia debido a que
el escape se dio en sus zonas económicas
exclusivas el origen aún no se ha
determinado pero la primera ministra
sueca Magdalena Anderson apunta a un
acto premeditado
tenemos inteligencias hueca pero también
hemos recibido información en nuestros
contactos con Dinamarca y en base a esto
lleguemos a la conclusión de que
probablemente se trate de un acto
deliberado probablemente sea una
cuestión de Sabotaje
una hipótesis que comparte Dinamarca que
por su parte declaró emergencia en los
sectores eléctricos Y gasísticos
al menos no podemos descartar la
posibilidad es demasiado pronto para
concluir algo pero en una situación
extra primaria es una situación inusual
y hay tres filtraciones incluso con
cierta distancia entre ellas y por lo
tanto es difícil imaginar que sería una
coincidencia pero es demasiado pronto
para concluir todavía y por lo tanto
estamos viendo esto con la mayor
severidad
del lado ruso aseguran que ya comenzaron
sus propias pesquisas
la presión realmente ha disminuido
significativamente la situación no tiene
precedentes y requiere una investigación
inmediata no se puede descartar ninguna
opción en este momento está claro que
hay daños en el gasoducto
la perspectiva ucraniana es otra un
asesor del presidente ucraniano
boludimir selenski sentenció que se
trata de un ataque ruso e incluso fue un
paso más allá
la fuga de gas de North Stream 1 no es
más que un ataque terrorista planeado
por Rusia y un acto de agresión hacia la
Unión Europea Rusia quiere destabilizar
la situación económica en Europa y
provocar el pánico antes del Invierno
mientras Las investigaciones avanzan y
los sismólogos de Dinamarca y Suecia
dieron a conocer que registraron
explosiones en las áreas de las fugas el
lunes Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
catalogaron los hechos de Sabotaje